we probably shouldn't box i i boxed i
had my boxing card and boxed pretty
consistently uh various times i'm not
very good you don't get a nose like this
do yoga
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i
andrew hueberman was just on the podcast
if you don't know who he is i'm going to
try and describe him very simply he's
this guy who works at stanford i believe
he's a neuroscience dr hubermann is his
name and he's got this youtube video uh
series and a podcast called huberman
labs where basically he picks one topic
like sleep stress
building muscle
um depression addiction and he'll do
like an hour to two hours of just
talking into the camera and talking to
his mic and explains
very easy ways to understand what it
means and how you can overcome or like
what supplements or what exercises you
can do to address he's only been around
for 10 months and he's already one of
the top 10 most popular podcasts he's
everywhere on youtube this guy is a
badass we just had him on the podcast i
would i'm kind of like starstruck a
little bit because i'm such a fan of his
um i think you're really gonna dig this
it's a little bit health focused
towards the end we get into a little bit
more business stuff but if you're into
business you have to be healthy
otherwise you're not gonna be able to
perform well and so we talk a lot about
that we talk a lot about morning
routines and these aren't just like well
i write my journal it's like well no if
you do this uh based off of science
based off peer review research if you do
this you're going to feel this way and
that's going to help with x y and z so
it's like kind of a evidence
research based podcast that we've just
done
it's pretty freaking cool so enjoy it
ben what do you think
um
he just
sean uses the term shortcuts he's really
good for giving little hacks i just feel
like i took away like
six to ten little hacks i can use in my
life that is gonna make it better mostly
biologically like it's going to actually
improve my sleep or uh
improve my ability to focus and things
like that so i think there's a lot of
great little nuggets for people in it
so check it out and by the way we are
giving a thousand dollars to six people
what you have to do is you go to rate
this podcast dot com slash mfm so that's
mfm as in my first million so rate this
podcast dot com slash mfm and leave us a
review all you gotta do is leave leave
us a review i don't even care it's a
negative review tell us how you think
about anything one star five star i
don't care do whatever you want and uh
at the end of the month we're gonna pick
like i think six of them and give a
thousand dollars away so rate this
podcast.com mfm write something cool
write something funny maybe if you stick
out we'll uh we'll pick you um let us
know what you think about the podcast
enjoy the episode
do you check notifications on youtube
uh i do not
okay so let me tell you something really
quick so about
two weeks ago so i'm a big uh bay area
punk rock fan so i listened to like i
used to live in san francisco for years
i listened to like old rancid old green
day and i was looking at an old
interview with tim armstrong from rancid
and it has like very little views and i
was loving this interview and i was
going to comment how much i love it and
i scrolled down and you were the first
comment on there
and i replied to you uh and so i thought
that was funny we have similar interests
i did not expect to see you there on an
old tim armstrong from
yeah i'm a huge uh rancid and tim
armstrong fan i mean without taking up
too much of our time on this i've never
i've never met tim personally um
but uh yeah growing up i was a operation
ivy fan big fan of a band called crimp
shrine this whole east bay punk scene
and then
um
rancid
came out and actually tim and matt
freeman had a band called downfall in
between
you can find some of those tracks and i
love those tracks
i just love it um they cover such a huge
range of styles and they've just done
amazing things and yeah so if there's
any content out there that's you know
rancid acoustic or
downfall rare rancid tracks i
scour the internet for them if i don't
know about them send them to me and as i
devour that stuff and we'll have sean
kind of do like an intro on you but
really quick this is one of the reasons
why i think people like you and why your
podcast has taken off because you're
this intellectual powerhouse but you
look like an athlete yet you kind of
have this like punk rock side to you
like you gotta tell that you have that
to you and i think that you're just like
a really like eclectic interesting
person and i think that's why
so basically sean you can do the intro
but you've had this podcast that just
launched like a year ago you're already
the biggest guy there is uh or top ten
top five it's pretty amazing um and i
think that's one of the reasons why why
you're you're kicking ass is because you
are quite eclectic and very different
from what we're used to
no go ahead i guess to say we can kind
of like set the scene so uh so we have
uh andrew huberman here dr hooverman and
uh known known for huberman lab and
you're a neuroscientist
uh professor at stanford and
you have a whole bunch of you have an
interesting podcast and i've seen you
everywhere recently so i don't know if
this is like i don't know if you have
hired an amazing pr person i don't know
if i'm just late to the party but you
went from i've never heard of you before
like three months ago let's say to i
only hear about you my youtube feed is
basically just giving me more and more
of your content every day so is that is
that a new thing or or am i just like
discovering it now
oh it's a it's a very new thing i mean
to just give you the quick arc um you
know leaving out all the pre-academia
stuff you know i did my training in
neuroscience and in physiology things
like temperature regulation and
things of that sort and over the years i
worked on a number of different problems
um
formally meaning in laboratories as a
phd student postdoc
a junior professor and tenured professor
things like stress and regeneration and
what happened was right around 2015 i
started getting curious about how
scientific information is making it out
into the general public
um but there really wasn't a a cause or
a venue for doing that there were these
meetings like big summit meetings and
things like that that weren't really my
flavor to be honest they're perfectly
fine but um they would typically go
something like you know yoga class group
of meditation one talk buy my product by
my book and then people go and so what
happened was in 2019 i have a good
friend his name is pat dossett
he's a wharton grad a former navy seal
operator um
did nine years in the seal teams he's a
good friend of mine we swim together um
he much further ahead than i of course
um you know those guys definitely have
extra gears um i've you know seen that
and and pat
uh also has a company called made for
which is a behavioral health company who
started with blake mykoski who's a
founder of tom's shoes so what happened
was that in 2019
pat asked me a question we were
literally getting out of the water we've
done an early morning cold water swim
and he said you know what are you going
to do in 2019 to make the world a better
place and i was like well you know i'm
trying to figure out neural regeneration
stress and how to sleep better in my lab
i said yeah what are you really gonna do
he was kind of poking at me and i said
well you know i think um
it'd be fun to just teach science on the
internet and just put quality
information out there because i don't
see that so i started doing that in 2019
little short posts pretty nerdy stuff
mostly on instagram
and people seem to like it and then in
20 and i got a book deal
um in 20 end of 2019 i thought i would
do what most academics do write a book
sell a book
and then 2020 hit and a couple things
happen one is i realized there was a
tremendous need for people to have the
tools for managing stress and circadian
rhythms and sleep and managing mental
workload and etc because everyone was
locked down and stressed out and
confused
as was i frankly um
but i had access to these tools so i
started disseminating the tools by going
on podcasts and on instagram and then
eventually the podcast led to a you know
the rogan appearance certainly had a lot
to do with it a rich role appearance um
that did uh well also in lex friedman at
the end of 2020
great podcaster and also a great friend
of mine now said you should start a
podcast so january
of 2021 bought the mics set it up i uh
looked to my skateboarding punk rock
past i have a friend named mike blayback
known as playback photo in the
skateboard in action sports community
shoots all the stuff of ginkana and ken
park driving rally cars of danny way
tony hawk all the
um they're only a few
superstars of skateboarding and action
sports photography mike happens to be
one of them and he said let's build an
aesthetic that kind of represents you i
always wear the same black shirt i own
26 of these that's not for the podcast
you know i i always keep my hair short
and just
you know this is me on any day it's just
that the kind of camera showed up and i
started sitting down and saying well
what would i do in a classroom if
someone was interested in stress and how
to manage stress well i would give four
lectures on that and so a big feature of
the podcast that's a little different is
that
than most podcast is that i try and stay
on theme
and i try and keep it
like i would in a classroom but then
offer a lot of tools which is a little
different so that's really how it
happened and uh no no pr firm no um
uh you know big no no contract signed
everything we've got with my team how
did you get on roads to one stage yeah
how'd you get on rogan because that was
a big obviously inflection point and
then that leads to tim ferriss that
leads to more and more so how'd you get
on rogan yeah and that was all this year
so then um well two things about that um
i'll just want to make sure i close the
hatch on so i haven't written this book
um i haven't released it for two reasons
one is that in 2020 i didn't want to
sell anything i was coming to the table
as an academic with a tenured position
and a salary frankly we don't make big
salaries even at stanford um yes if my
dean is listening the salaries at
stanford are not in keeping with the
cost of living in the bay area which is
why most people sit on company boards
and things of that sort so um you do
science for the love of it um but i
didn't want to talk about my work
um and be self-promotional i really love
learning and teaching and i have one
mission in my professional life and
that's to share the magic and the
utility of biology i i mean that's for
me just fills me up and talking about my
work is fun we can do that if you want
but there's so much terrific work out
there so what happened was the second
rogan appearance is you know joe said
you know
huberman's doing this podcast thing and
people seem interested in it let's get
them back on to share some of this
information
and but how did it happen in the first
place well
i have a good friend and business
partner at my podcast
um his name is rob moore and no he's not
taking new clients um so because he no
longer does what i'm about to describe
which is that rob uh came from the world
of of pr but then he got really
interested in podcasts he's in his
mid-thirties and he started a podcast
called the fight with teddy atlas he
loves boxing he really likes it oh yeah
yeah yeah i listen to that every week
yeah okay you work you work with that
guy yeah he's got like a thick boston
accent right uh that's ken rideout who's
a friend who i met through rob rob
you're not going to see you're not going
to find he sits behind an email wall and
he's a a close friend of mine um
that
you know october this time last year
october november of 2020 we went for
lunch and i said let's start a podcast
lex thinks that we've got traction with
a podcast and i think he's right and he
said great let's do it let's buy the
mics let's you know we built the studio
with our own hands mike showed up got
the dc team in there because they're
friends with of mine um dc shoes dc
skateboarding and they helped me you
know create an aesthetic that we thought
would would work for make people feel
like they were in a classroom um and
you know rob uh was the one who
connected me to the person who connected
me to joe uh there's a little bit of i
since this is a public venue there's a
little bit of a of a wall there just
because they get flooded with requests
and i'll be honest you know i don't know
what their process is um
i think that they have a process and and
if i'm not privy to it i think that
what's beautiful about the rogan podcast
having been a guest on there and
obviously a big fan is that they i think
what you see is the real deal uh you
know joe sits down with people that he'd
like to have a meal with and or
conversation with and has a conversation
and um and the human appetite for that
is obviously huge uh people seem to
really resonate with that and of course
joe is a tremendous reason um so he's
been tremendously helpful tim ferriss uh
rich roll and lex friedman and
i will say that lex has been my uh kind
of guiding light in this whole process
about
bringing certain elements of my own
person and personality to things you
know yeah i am
i mean this is going to sound weird to
anyone who's looking to this for science
information but and it might not even
make sense but sam you'll get it and
i don't know other people will too which
is like yeah i'm a died in the wool
punk rocker i grew up in that and if
this that scene i think people think of
as like loud music loud clothes loud
everything that scene at its at is
essence the reason i gravitated towards
it early is that it's
very varied it's about showing up like
heartful
strong it's not a it's never a victim
stance but it's not an aggressive stance
but it's not a weak stance either and
for me it just resonated and so it's
like let's you know the opening track of
my um podcast for instance is a song i
don't um want to get the copyright
people on me so uh
that's familiar from the punk rock
culture and i just wanted to bring all
that forward and i think lex was the one
who really said
pick two or three things that you really
feel
represent your relationship to science
and that give you energy for that lexus
is a genius i have to say what you see
there with the jacket and tie and all
the interviews lex works so hard he
thinks so hard
about
where he's going with all this and he
just interviewed the director of the
national institutes of health francis
collins that is not an easy grab
um so in any case that's a long-winded i
don't tend to be succinct so i'll stop
yeah i want to ask you about i'll ask
you about lex in a second but for those
who who are listening and don't know who
you are basically i i have your channel
up right now so your first video was
launched 10 months ago your video is
basically you
and you're this is weird to say to you
but you're you're like a good-looking
dude you've got like a goatee you look
kind of like a football player you're
you're wearing you're wearing a black
shirt with a black background you're
pretty serious
um and you're just sitting for like 60
minutes to almost two hours sometimes
and you're explaining things that sound
complicated like how your nervous system
works and changes master your sleep um
using failures movements and balance to
learn faster so these are like things
that are somewhat complicated but you
sit down and you look at the camera for
one to two hours and you tell you you
you explain what what it all means and
then you do something that's interesting
where it says like all right so how do
you take advantage of this and apply
this and use this um and you're
long-winded on purpose because you said
you're like i'm not gonna i need you to
know exactly how this works so you can
decide what you want to do versus
me just telling you exactly what to do
yeah there's like a balance of uh
you can simplify something so people can
understand it without dumb
remove their own agency to to to to dive
in
yeah yeah thanks for that description
you know my um like i said that the goal
and and really my purpose in life i know
mission statements and purpose sound
kind of they're kind of cliche and but
it is really is i get i so i have this
process that i've used for a long time
which is
i like to just
pay attention to what puts energy into
my body um the music like i'll hear a
song you're familiar with this you hear
a song like yes you know it just fills
you with energy whether or not that's
dopamine or adrenaline or we could
dissect that but that's not the point
but that energy
is a is a neural energy it doesn't have
to do with calories it doesn't but that
energy is your source right like in the
eastern philosophies they would call it
chi or whatever it is so i've always
sensed what i really enjoy and for me
learning cool information and sharing it
is what i want to do so what i try and
do is
paint a a tapestry at the beginning of
here's a topic like stress or sleep or
dopamine or adhd or eating disorders or
whatever and arm people with the
language and make them realize that the
nomenclature is just words we can
replace some of those words and let's
get a functional definition of things
going and then once they understand how
things work a little bit some of the the
algorithms so to speak then let's talk
about what you can do with this and how
you can use light to change your
circadian rhythms or
particular patterns of breathing that
are grounded in physiology to de-stress
rapidly etc and so yeah
and can you explain this first video so
your first video
is only sean was saying that like you're
you came everywhere you're everywhere
very quickly your first one was only 10
months ago that first video has 652 000
views it's a slick looking thumbnail can
you walk me through how much did you
spend to build that studio and like how
did the first traction do you think come
to this video your very first video 650
000. the very next one looks like a
month later
a million views the next one 630 i mean
you hit right away
you were
you were hitting right away how did that
happen
yeah that's a good question so a big
part of that
was i don't think it was the thumbnails
because actually we were told by youtube
that our thumbnails
weren't legible i had these fancy
anatomical drawings
you know that uh now we've changed them
a bit um we've learned some things you
know faces do better than images etc but
if you thumbnails that are really
clickbaity are thumbnails where
someone's going like where they said the
wider the eyes the more people click and
kind of crazy
stuff um we didn't do that because i
want people to know that i'm here with a
serious you know serious information
because i'm serious about them it's sort
of like why always the black shirt these
are actually the blacks i am literally
on 26 of these that i like these
particular shirts um i'm not trying to
get picked up by the by the maker so i
won't mention it but i've always worn
them i like like them but also
me and sean always wear black typically
because it's easy to hide if you're fat
or wrinkles right or tattoos not that
i'm confessing that i have any tattoos
but the uh if i was neck to knuckles
tattoos i would just do it but i'm not
but the um and kids uh yes you should be
able to dress however you want do
whatever you want but that's not the way
the world works people are always
evaluating so you decide it's your
gamble i always say authenticity is not
the same as over sharing
these days i think there's a big
tendency to think oh because you can
deadlift 500 pounds that you should put
that on the internet um
one so this is part of my answer which
is that by the end of 2020 the instagram
channel had grown to several hundred
thousand but that mind you took two
years and a 50 5-0 podcast appearances
as a guest
so
um we announced that we were going to
launch a youtube channel to get over
there and subscribe
and then
we just started pushing out content
frequency is a big deal um
you know we do one a week we may advance
to one and a shorter one um each week
next time but
you know free consistency you know not
surprisingly counts and
there's consistency of aesthetic too uh
you know this the building the studio
was fairly straightforward um thank you
mike playback my good friend and dc i
mean
the one thing about skateboarders that
they really really know how to do well
is to create original content in a diy
format okay so actually mike is out on a
shoot right now uh with spike jones
right so i grew up with i don't know
spike but i grew up with a lot of the
guys who ride for girl mike spike jones
owns girls a portion of girl skateboards
so i grew up around people that took
video of us playing around on the
streets on skateboards and made videos
that became these iconic things
and so well skateboarders were kind of
like the first youtubers uh you know if
you look at old transworld or 411 videos
or old dc or
like the like like what bam was doing
with jackass you know
it was the cky videos we were the
skaters were the first youtubers
that's right though they really were and
um you mentioned 4-1-1 so you definitely
you know 4-1-1 is like no i still skate
i i was just hanging out with mikey
mikey taylor this weekend professional
skateboarder skateboarding
yeah yeah
yeah and to be clear because i want to
maintain my um
integrity with that community i wasn't a
great skateboarder i was okay uh thunder
trucks put me on out of sympathy
spitfire put me on out of sympathy um
but i wasn't gonna be one of the big
guys it was just a community i really
felt a part of and when i went off to
college because my high school
girlfriend went to college i tripped and
fell into biology i thought i'd be a
skateboarder or a firefighter or
something was more physical but i fell
in love with biology and and just that's
what i've been doing ever since but i
think the aesthetic keeping a
fairly narrow messaging too you know
we've turned down
every option to make a little bit of
extra money doing affiliate codes i mean
we do have advertising and affiliate
codes but to just pepper
things with you know advertising
everywhere we just i want people
to have a zero-cost
trusted source for
science health and fitness information
of course we're not going to get
everything exactly right but to know
that if they come to the hubermann lab
channel
that they're going to get information
that's vetted that i've i always consult
with at least two or three colleagues
professional in a given area before i do
a podcast of just me because i don't
work on adhd i know the
a fair amount about it but i consult
with experts and so i have a kind of
advisory board so i use the scientific
community and it's a kind of a beautiful
um ecosystem where our advertisers are
happy we're happy our but the main thing
is the consumers get it at zero cost to
consumer and i think that's very
different than a book
and that's very different than a behind
paywall strategy i've seen a lot of
health and science uh podcasters who are
quite good move their stuff behind a
paywall because you can make much more
money charging you know 10 30 a month or
something and i like to think that
people would be willing to do that for
our content however i feel best about
the fact that for some kid sitting in
halfway across the world who wants to
understand
weight training or adhd or dopamine or
sleep they just as long as they have an
internet connection
they have to tolerate a few ads but the
information is free to them what why
don't you just bail as a
million dollars a year
uh well i i'm
i'm i guess academically masochistic
because um well it's it's interesting
i'm happy to announce this now i
actually took um
i i love doing research
uh we have a big project on human stress
we've
been working on human fear i love doing
research and actually a fairly sizable
portion of the huberman lab podcast
income is going to be donated to
research and to scholarships for
students um i i'm not i'd be very honest
i'm not i
i'm not extremely wealthy nor do i um
suffer you know i and i
i it's money is important i always say
money but can't buy happiness but it
absolutely can buffer stress
no question about that um anyone who's
ever had
significant funds throughout their
lifetime don't truly understand that
statement people who haven't will
understand exactly what i mean
and i
i think money is very important but
so is the ecosystem between academia
public health and science communication
and the private sector and
for the time being it just makes sense
for me to continue to teach at stanford
i teach medical students in the winter
on neuroanatomy i direct the
neuroanatomy course and
i really enjoy academic conversations um
they're slow
it's like leading through steel one
thin layer at a time but what you get
too often is a kind of granularity
where it's a process it's it's not so
much you get to answers it's you get to
a process of getting to answers
um and i don't think i'd be happy
without doing that
actually a couple people
fans of the pod and they are i knew they
would be excited to have you on because
we we mostly this is a business oriented
podcast that's why kind of we're asking
you some things about the business of
how you
you became a content creator how you got
your audience
you know why do you
sean we've not even we've not even told
them what we do i guess i i i didn't
well i i did i did a little bit of
research um
and i i was delighted when you guys
asked i mean i'm new to twitter
uh frankly i didn't like twitter when i
first got on i was like wow people are
really combative compared to instagram
um and i think it's because you don't
have to show your face and i'm a very
like i'm not an aggressive person but if
somebody goes wants to go toe-to-toe i
still have that in me i'm not suggesting
anyone get violent out there but people
would come at me and on instagram and
start well show yourself let's go you
know like let's have a conversation and
um you know so i don't get into back and
forth in comments i found twitter to be
an incredibly combative neighborhood
and then you guys showed up i was like
oh wow i guess there's some nice people
in the neighborhood so sort of like
finding the other punk rockers and
skateboarders it's like you and me we
got the same thing and we're good so
that's that was the feeling i had and
then it turns out that's actually the
case
twitter you get rewarded every network
rewards you for a different
wit which is like the plus side so you
know being witty in 140 characters but
then on the other side it's basically uh
you know if you have the sharpest insult
at somebody you also get rewarded and
you don't have to show your face and
there's all these other benefits and so
so it brings out a different side it's
actually youtube used to be this way too
the youtube comments i don't know if
people remember this but youtube
comments used to be the running joke as
like what is the most cesspool of the
toxic commentary that exists it was
called the youtube comments and now
youtube comments are extremely i don't
know what they changed in the algorithm
or the the flagging or what what not but
youtube comments are on the whole you
know either funny or supportive or
whatnot they really change that tic toc
is doing it
um but anyways one thing about comments
uh before i forget started interrupt but
vis-a-vis business because i know that's
your your main audience is one thing
that i did on instagram early on and
then i do on youtube is
comment sections are great but better to
make them interactive so i actively
request and we read every single comment
i say tell me but give me give us
feedback but also give us suggestions
and give us ideas about future podcasts
and then i've devoted entire episodes we
haven't done one in a while but to what
we call office hours which is where i go
through the most frequently asked
questions and address those so now
there's an incentive to ask to put stuff
in the comments and i think that's a
really good non-combative use of the
comments section and we of course still
get some uh crazy stuff in the comments
and people being combative but um they
should just know that we don't actually
read those no i'm kidding we read them
all
yeah for sure um so i wanted to talk
about a couple things one was what we
talked about now how how did you where
how did you break out what
and i think it's great you know i teach
science on the internet it's such a
simple
a simple like sort of philosophy a
simple you know business statement of
what do i do what am i here to do and
then the mission i enjoyed that as well
but i wanna actually go through some of
those greatest hits so some of the
reasons that you've grown in popularity
is that you put out nuggets that are
interesting to people and when i was
talking to friends saying you were
coming on they said
you know we ask a lot of the kind of
like
oh you know we have a billionaire on the
podcast hey you're super successful
what's your morning routine and they
tell us oh you know here's what i do in
the morning you know and people sort of
equate that to if i do this i i too will
become a billionaire which is obviously
not not the right way to think about it
but i think if i ask you about your
morning routine which i'm guessing is
centered around
health mental health uh fitness um and
sort of regulating your body that that
actually will be applicable to more
people so take us through what is the uh
what is the morning routine i know
you've talked about this on some other
pods but i i bet the majority of our
audience has not listened to all your
stuff so you know these are the greatest
hits let's let's do them sure
yes so uh i wake up uh for me that's
usually somewhere around
somewhere between
5 30 and 6 30 depending on how early i
went to sleep
uh i wake up and i do an assessment of
whether or not i feel rested or not
most days the answer is no
just because of uh life
staying up too late uh stress etc so i
do a 10 to 30 minute yoga nidra session
first thing in the morning
uh yoga nidra is a passive listening you
can find these yoga nidra links uh on
youtube there's one which is 10 minute
yoga nidra um there's one that actually
made four put out for free called um
nsdr non-sleep deep breaths that's a 30
minute one it's a script where you just
listen it brings your brain into a state
that's like that's pseudo sleep
after that 10 or 30 minute yoga nidra i
feel like i've slept as much as i need
to sleep it's a really remarkable reset
and it it avoids your brain going into
this state of planning and organization
what we call duration path and outcome
in the neural circuitry uh world and
keeps it in that kind of liminal state
of adjusting and there are some
interesting data
published showing that these yoganidra
meditations if you will are uh can
upregulate some of the neurotransmitters
in the brain including dopamine that
make you prepared for action
and so uh they're very restorative
especially in the absence of complete
sleep if i feel great i might just get
out of bed the first thing is always and
i have to be careful because to list
every step because sometimes people say
wait he doesn't even go to the bathroom
in the morning i mean obviously i go
right foot left foot to the bathroom
then i use the restroom then i go
downstairs i drink water i hydrate and i
go outside and i get some sunlight in my
eyes for 10 to 30 minutes
foundational absolutely critical
practice when i don't do it for more
than two days in a row i start messing
up all sorts of aspects of my life
and most people are not doing this even
on cloudy days do it
don't wear sunglasses
unless you have a medical reason why you
need to it's fine to wear corrective
lenses or contacts
you don't need to stare directly at the
sun
or see the sun rise and these are the
questions i most often get this is why
i'm hitting these as bullet points and
if you wake up before the sun rises flip
on as many lights as you can in your
space if you want to be awake in your
artificial light environment and then
once the sun is out go outside i don't
care if you're in the depths of
scandinavian winter the sun comes out at
some point
some people might need a daylight
simulator but the discussion about
daylight simulators is usually an excuse
to avoid having to just go outside and
get sunlight in your eyes for 10 to 30
minutes you can check your phone if you
want or bring the newspaper if people
still read those or a book i usually
bring a journal
and i write down some things that i want
to do that day and try and make sure
that i'm clearing away some of the
clutter um
if you have a dog you could do this
while walking etc and then i sometimes
will combine this with a walk
optic flow when you're just walking
through space
not looking at anything like your phone
or anything in particular
that optic flow is known to
suppress a circuit in the limbic system
that involves the threat detection
centers it is very calming to walk
through space and it reduces your
overall levels of anxiety many people
just being indoors not getting sunlight
uh not getting enough sleep life is
stressful they're not doing this so
basically all of that can be
accomplished in one hour it's wake up
yoga ninja for 10 to 30 minutes
use the bathroom drink some water of
course all the basic biological
functions what about um
thianine and coffee
okay so i don't ingest theanine during
the day i ingest it as part of a sleep
cocktail before sleep some people will
take l-theanine with coffee it's now in
many energy drinks because it uh takes
away some of the
jitters that
it's a mild sedative and it takes away
some of the jitters that caffeine can
induce i don't drink any caffeine until
90 minutes or ideally 120 minutes after
i've woken up
for the following reason
uh
during sleep you
well during wakefulness
you and the longer you're awake
adenosine builds up in your system
caffeine is an adenosine antagonist
functionally i realize it's a
competitive agonist for you aficionados
but it it basically blocks the adenosine
receptor functionality so to speak
but when that caffeine wears off you're
gonna get a big crash because there's
gonna be a surplus of adenosine by
waiting 90 minutes to two hours to
ingest caffeine 90 minutes or two hours
after waking to ingest caffeine it's a
little bit of a struggle to learn how to
do this but your natural adenosine
system that adenosine tapers down very
very low as a consequence and you don't
get that rebound in the afternoon i
drink
mate a yerba mate tea i love it um
there's a great br i don't like that the
uh really smoky ones i have no business
relationship to any yerba mate company
by the way but the one i love is by i
don't know who this person is or if it's
even a person's anna park it's a really
delicious one it comes loose leaf and
um it's very high caffeine content so
you don't need very much of it and it
also has a lot of what's called glp-1
glucagon like peptide 1 which is
actually being used now as an
anti-diabetes and obesity drug
there's all sorts of great things about
glp1 upregulates dopamine receptors etc
so i'll drink mate starting about 90
minutes after i'm awake
and then
that's kind of my morning but
after the walk i go inside i i do try to
avoid social media at that point maybe a
quick check of 10 minutes i said i'll
even set an alarm um and then
on a phone or computer typically on a
phone i'd like to move more to the
computer but i've been transit a lot
these days and um
you have to uh be thoughtful obviously
but i think maybe 10 minutes on social
media but i want social media to
continue to be a pleasure and because of
the dopamine system and we can talk
about that
i don't want to get i don't want to go
down the rabbit hole of someone else's
um
psychology or neurology
i want to stay in my own frame the
orientation i have in the early part of
the day
with that notebook is
i want to be in my own mental frame i've
just slept during sleep is when we have
neuroplasticity the actual rewiring of
neural connections occurs during sleep
i'm a big believer in the subconscious
and you're when you wake up you are now
in a position to
extract whatever it is that these new
neural circuits have have figured out
about the previous day and days events
and so if i immediately bombard myself
with sensory experience
or input or distractions
i'm not able to
do that so this morning for instance
i'll just give an example i'm preparing
an episode of the podcast on time
perception i've been reading a lot about
this and i woke up this morning went
outside with the notebook and just sat
there
and then realized that there's a way to
organize this episode that has to do
with frame rates and sort of slow motion
versus fast motion
cognition or hopefully it'll be clear by
time the podcast happens it's not fully
formed but that can be so i wrote that
down thought great and then um i'll move
into some more typical type work uh it's
great if you can avoid email until after
12 noon but that's very hard for a lot
of businesses so i will usually do a
brief check in on email critical items
but then i like to write so i will
i'm working i am working on a book
finally
i will work on scientific papers on
grants on reviewing papers i try and
make that pretty heavy intellectual
lifting um
and take that until about noon
and then i'll i'll look into and then we
can talk about you know food and other
things at this point i haven't eaten
anything do you ever so you have not
eaten till noon but one thing that you
met did not bring up and i'm wondering
do you have a family
uh no i have a relationship and i had a
dog until recently he passed away so i i
do understand people have different
things yeah i have different constraints
he was a big part of my morning routine
i had this big 90-pound bulldog mastiff
named costello and we would slowly do
our walk we'd get the sun together
animals are perfectly happy to do these
because these are very innate behaviors
but no kids
no children
you know who are children in my life
i'll say that but but i don't have any
children yeah you remind me of henry
rollins
except his except his jaw goes to about
here right you know like henry's head is
like this big right sean do you know who
henry rollins is no
one time i shot okay shawn doesn't know
who dolly parton is he didn't know who
jimmy buffett was
sean doesn't know like white people
um and so we're gonna put this in the
category of white people henry
rollins was he was it black flag that he
was the lead singer of yeah so well all
right i have to be careful not to go
down this path too i mean i'm a big ian
mackay fan so minor threat right then
minor threat
and then there was black flag so and yes
but rollins was part of black flag um
and uh he was early in the punk rock
scene to
get into lifting weights a lot ian and
those guys were straight edge straight
edge means different things in different
eras but at that time it meant no
alcohol no drugs it's pretty firm stance
in the 80s compared to uh the rest of
the culture yeah um i don't know henry i
don't know ian um but i listen to minor
threat all the time but sean so
henry is like this guy he's like this
punk rocker he's like he might be in his
60s now but probably
he basically like was singing punk rock
but he would didn't drink or anything
and he started lifting weights so he was
like uh kind of like a meathead a little
bit and not a bad way but he was like
jacked and now at this point in his life
he's completely single he doesn't have
kids or anything and he's a poet and
he's an actor and he's just look kind of
like a renaissance man where and if you
google him you'll recognize him did you
google him he's uh
he's like you'll definitely recognize
him he was um in he was he's sometimes
in movies sons of anarchy things like
that and anyway just this like really
really interesting guy and he'll go in
like a ted talk or something like that
and he'll just talk about his philosophy
on anything he's kind of like mike tyson
a little bit he just kind of like every
time he talks it's just like wisdom
um anyway uh huberman has this like uh
just like henry rollins vibe a little
bit and that's why i was asking about
kids because you're this interesting guy
who's kind of like i s in my head i
picture you as this like guy who's alone
intensely studying and trying to figure
out like crack a problem and i think
that that's really in that's just like
an interesting part of you at least yeah
in my head that's what i'm making you up
as sure i mean i i
in the spirit of um authenticity but not
over sharing uh what i can say about
this is um i mean i'm blessed with great
friendships i've always i think because
of that skateboarding punk rock era
because it was mostly guys back then i
have a community a lot of friends who
you know swim who work out who uh play
music i'm really good friends with a guy
named michael muller who's a
photographer who does all the marvel
stuff and um i'll train with him i train
i'm sometimes up at uh laird hamilton
and gabby reese's pool i like those
workouts they're good friends of mine
when i'm down there but yes i at this
point in my life um i live in a somewhat
remote area uh i have a gym and a sauna
and a cold dunk
i spend a lot of time with the books i
i'm dying to get another dog and i do
live that kind of monastic lifestyle um
i do have a relationship
and that's great and uh you know the
children thing is interesting because i
started off studying brain development
and neuroplasticity and brain
development and so
let's just say that if i do something i
do it a hundred percent so i have no
children now but if i do have kids i i
genuinely want five of them i want a big
family or none at all so that's uh so
that's a plan we should talk because
you're you're kind of your specialty
is around the eye right and i've heard
you say this before
and i'm gonna
i is essentially part of the brain that
exists outside of the the sort of the
cranium where the rest of the brain is
stored it's actually like you know
that's right it is the same is it what
the same tissue or it's like
developmentally that it like kind of
segregated at some point but it's
basically it's the only part of your
brain that's like facing the world out
that's right uh you got you got several
points there right and none of them
wrong
these two bits are two pieces of your
central nervous system they got extruded
out of the skull or we should say out of
the cranial vault because technically
they're still in the skull um extruded
out of the cranial vault during
development and they are
the way that your brain figures out
where it is in space and time
right um by the rising and setting of
the sun
and the changing of the
of the amount of light throughout the
year regardless of where you live and uh
they are
responsible for
delivering 40 percent of the inf uh
let's just say 40 of the brains real
estate is devoted to vision in some way
or another we are incredibly visual
animals uh especially
even in blind people that real estate
for vision that's in the back of the
head the so-called occipital cortex is
overtaken by areas that respond to touch
and hearing that's why they're so good
at tactile and hearing but
incited individuals
vision is the predominant way not just
that we represent and see objects around
us oh blue car um tall
good looking woman or man whatever it is
it's also the way that we orient
ourselves in space and time and that we
set our frame rate um and we can talk
about this but
essentially you when as you move through
life
you're either batching time in big
chunks or in small chunks and that has
to do with how you're viewing the visual
world so you're either thinking in slow
motion or thinking it fast
depending on your visual environment
that's probably a little abstract but
yes these two bits are brain outside
your cranial vault
why you say kind of in the morning you
want to go
uh
you know one of the key things of your
morning routine was get outside let the
sun hit your eyes
it's basically alerting the body that
hey the sun is up kickstart all your
start your engines because it's daytime
is regulating that way
and i think there's different things
throughout the day that you've talked
about
anxiety maybe help you go to sleep
and um i'll give you kind of two
questions that came from the audience
that when i tweeted out that you were
coming on they're both in the same vein
and so one question is
um we talk a lot on this podcast about
the 80 20 right we are fans of the
shortcut uh shortcuts get a bad rap
around the world uh you know it's sort
of seen as the the lazy i don't care
thing to do but in many ways a shortcut
is great a shortcut is basically saying
how do i identify the highest leverage
points
that if i did those i would get maybe
the biggest impact or how do i get the
results i want faster instead of slower
and so what would be the 80 20 meaning
if you could change for all the people
who are listening to this right so
imagine a hundred thousand people
listening to this right now
if you could implant sort of one or two
behavior changes that they could do in
the day so maximum of two
which two would you pick that you think
have the highest roi the highest return
uh for the investment of what it takes
to do them what do you think would make
people happier
it doesn't matter anything that's
anything to make you feel better have a
yeah whether it's improve your health or
improve the way you feel throughout the
day uh what would be the one or two that
you would point to as like you're kind
of
yeah so you know it's a great question i
think we need to think about
foundational practices um and the two
things that set the foundation for
optimal
mental and
physical functioning are going to be
really good sleep and really good mental
frame and mental frame is going to be
the ability to toggle between different
states of mind and so let me give you
the practices first so that i don't get
accused of being an
intellectual to the point of um
you know curing insomnia right during
this podcast the first one is
that morning sunlight in your eyes
should be a non-negotiable thing
360 days out of the year if it's raining
stand under an overhang i'm very
unsympathetic to that well i wake up and
it's early and then i gotta drive to
work stand outside for five minutes i i
don't you know i i got plenty of rest
last night so i'm not ornery about this
but
i've grown a little bit exhausted of
that well
you know i can't do that because i've
got kids right take them outside with
you they need this too
that sets
a cortisol increase in the morning which
is a healthy cortisol increase that
provides wakefulness
triggers your metabolism in the proper
direction if that cortisol spike happens
too late because you didn't view light
then you step out during noon
too often remember one day is no big
deal but step out in the sunlight too
late off too
often late in the day you have a delayed
cortisol spike which is associated with
insomnia depression there are good data
on this so get that morning sunlight 360
days out of the year you will thank me i
promise um everything gets better now
it's a slow subtle shift
it's not like popping you know 1000
milligrams of l-tyrosine and drinking a
double espresso and going to the gym
it's not a it's not um
it's a foundational practice so i like
to think of it as it raises the tide so
that your boat can leave harbor that's
how i think of it
rather than oh this is like putting
another outboard motor on on my vessel
okay
so that's the first one and the second
one is a little bit of a broader
category but it gets sleep right
you have
if you're
until you're sleeping well 80 of the
time
or more get your sleep right and for
this i can just defer people we do have
a newsletter it's completely free but we
have our privacy policy we don't share
your email it's at hubermanlab.com just
go to newsletter all the prior
newsletters are listed there's
the key tips for sleep you can watch the
master your sleep episode or you can
just download that 12 steps for optimal
sleep yes there is a segment on
supplementation with some of the
considerations and warnings
there's also
sections on non-sleep deep breast
protocols links to those so get your
sleep right and get that light er in
your eyes early in the day if you're a
blind person
there's another protocol i've done some
work with blind people to try and help
them with this many blind people still
maintain the cells in their eyes that
can reset the can set these mechanisms
what's the mental framework
yeah so mental frame is something that
i don't think has been formalized in the
kind of health and fitness uh
optimization sean's really good at that
by the way like sean
shawn is very good at that where he he
does a really good job at deciding what
what frame he's going to be in
uh i put it differently my my the number
one priority my number one mission the
thing i work on is not even my bit
being able to being able to be in the
state of mind i want so which is
basically being able to experience the
experiences i want the way i want to
beautiful i just made it my top priority
in life so then i started to get good at
it because i realized oh this is
the cheat code this is like you know
you've got stressed out uh billionaire
over there and then you've got you know
joyful uh single mom over here and like
what's which quality of life do i
actually want well
i want the one where my state of mind uh
is in these states that i enjoy and not
fear anxiety stress depression not these
other states that i'm trying to uh not
have as
that's my quick quick rant on
yeah no it's great mental frame is is is
so key and um most i will say uh and i
want to be very respectful of everything
all the work that's preceded when i
showed up um but you know a lot of the
stuff that's out there in the self-help
and business literature
um
it frankly is kind of nipping at the
margins of some of this stuff like um
and look i don't want to throw out names
because it becomes disparaging i think
the one person who really deserves a nod
who's truly a pi they're two people who
are incredible pioneers in this space
and one is cal newport right so so good
they can't ignore you is incredible book
everyone should be required to read that
book um deep work
is this i'm essentially paraphrasing
some of the protocols from deep work but
cal who i don't know have never met but
have great respect for um it's a
computer science professor uh back east
um uh
it's about setting mental frame and
context switching is dangerous which
book which which book are you saying
so he has a book so good they can't
ignore you which was written some years
ago and that was more towards like not
trying to find your passion but getting
really good at skills um but deep work
is an excellent book um he has he's not
on social media but he has given some
ted talks um
and that book is about uh getting in the
right frame it's sort of like it's a lot
about flow right
it's about
not
succumbing to distractions so you can do
work that actually moves the needle but
that's not what you're talking about is
it i thought that you were talking no so
yeah then there's another one which is a
world without email that he wrote
recently here's the key essence of the
cal newport work okay the the key
essence of it as it relates to mental
frame is that the brain is extremely
good at end the body at context
switching like i could be doing this
podcast right now and if a fire alarm
goes off or someone comes knocking on
the door i can switch up my context and
respond to that but
90 of the work that we are
that
moves the needle meaning that we are
rewarded for or that enriches
professional life and relationships
it we used to talk about this about
mindfulness and presence but it's really
about getting the brain to start doing
certain operations more uh in a more
facile way and this is why habits are
important but
because going to the gym is different
than reviewing a paper or writing a
scientific paper is different than
podcasting or being a guest on a podcast
for that matter so what happens is early
in the day when you get the download
from sleep you identify a few things
that are key you've already you're
starting to funnel your neural networks
toward what i'm calling frame setting
and what you're not doing is allowing
something that came in from the external
environment to adjust your frame so you
get a depth of connection with the work
a depth like i knew i was doing this
podcast today at noon and i wasn't
walking and thinking about it but i set
that as a as a goal post and
because i wrote it down my brain is
orienting toward what i need to do so
that when we clip on we're ready to go
and so mental frames are very important
context switching is deadly i'm stealing
cal's word so forgive me cal um some
people will put freedom the the computer
program so that they are not able to
engage with the internet um this device
which i've turned off or i guess it is
on but it's on airplane mode for the
podcast i try and keep away from me for
the first half of the day very hard very
hard especially when you need to post on
social media but i try
and i want to have here's the goal in
the morning to make this simple i want
to have one 90-minute block that i
completely conquer
that i that is where i experience
immense resistance to do something other
than what i'm doing but that i stay in
in
noodling away or gnawing away would be
the better word at writing something or
reading something or trying to
comprehend something and you have to be
very careful the moment you walk to the
restroom and then maybe like wash your
hands and look yourself in the mirror
and then you're like oh you know i got
this weird hair growing on my cheek or
something you're starting to switch
mental frame and so 90 minutes seems
like nothing but it is remarkable what
you can accomplish with this but the
more important aspect
is that
in that exercise of getting good at what
we call no-go operations in the brain
you have go and no-go operations in
pushing aside things and enforcing those
blinders you're able to bring that same
mental frame
to other things later in the day and in
life and you're able to engage it much
quicker it's sort of like if you're a
car
you drive a car and you've never been up
to 110 miles an hour you don't really
know how to get around a a semi in front
of you that's breaking fast and you're
on a downhill but when you have to do it
you can do it you're comfortable at
speed
and you're comfortable breaking and so
that this mental frame thing is not just
about the work you're able to do in that
90 minutes it's about getting better at
doing deep work even for shorter bouts
because as the day goes on we all have
this experience right things start
coming in we start getting bombarded and
we're starting to get that that kind of
fragmentation of our of our goals and
we're kind of getting pulled off and
some people that the the peak time is in
the afternoon some people it's in the
morning some people play at night but
you're getting yanked off center and so
you have to be able to recognize just
how delicious
and effective that state is
and then you can apply it later and i'll
let people use their imagination but
this comes into into use in many aspects
of life that have nothing to do with
work okay like being able to stay at
that at that groove with somebody or in
some
interaction or on a run i mean you know
use your imagination this is the the
important thing is it's all the same
circuit it's this engagement of the
prefrontal cortex which is saying
duration path outcome meaning what how
long is this gonna how long should i do
this what path should i take what
outcomes am i getting in real time
and not getting pulled off center by
someone else's dpo as i call them dpos
in incidentally or not so incidentally
i've been fortunate enough to do some
work with the special operations
community in the canada and the u.s in
addition to those guys being really good
at shoot move and communicate the really
exceptional ones know how to flip this
switch on we think of it as like grit
resilience and mental toughness and yes
they're all gritty but they're a lot of
gritty people out there the difference
is
the ability to take
your environment narrow that environment
and be effective
and cut a fine slice through something
and then stop and move to something else
that's a
mental operation that involves multiple
circuits multiple neurotransmitters we
couldn't say just dopamine just
epinephrine or something like that it's
gonna be that but a bunch of other
things too and so 90 minutes like
learn that 90 minute battle and it takes
time and then you get very very good at
so i'll podcast for two hours i drop
into that that's the state i'm in when i
podcast two quick questions one what do
you suck at because when i talk to you
i'm incredibly intimidated because uh
when it comes to mental health and
physical health and emotional health i'm
like i'm so inadequate because well i
like i i read your watch your youtube to
see like you know i stink at this
therefore i want to learn what you're
saying so i can be better and then and
when i hang out with you now i'm like
this guy's got it together i know that's
not the case you're a human you've got
issues just like me that's not the case
so i want to know what do you struggle
with and also
do you just have loads of people
dropping in your dms hitting on you
because i hear you talking i'm like this
guy
he's probably
or is it all just dudes is it all just a
bunch of dudes like instead of you
pictures of like a mole on their back
asking what they what you think it is
um how do you know i don't find moles on
backs incredibly fast i'm just kidding
every doctor has that they just all my
doctor friends it's all just half of us
say like hey what do you think this lump
is
exactly um
so okay so um just to make sure i close
the hatch on that so you asked for two
tools i gave three morning sunlight
master your sleep you can see that
newsletter uh for that the tools and
then
this 90 minute
bat and look some days it goes better
than others but remember it's not just
about what you accomplish it's about
getting into those frames and you're
controlling it this is i guess i wish i
had said this before is that you are
setting the beginning middle and end of
that frame that's what's key it's not
happening because someone else said game
time noon on sunday and you're showing
up anyone can do that with some practice
what you're learning how to do is is
flip the switch you're learning how to
engage that but you have to be very
judicious in your use of this circuitry
you can't do it for 12 hours a day so
that's when i do email and all the other
stuff okay like 290 minute bouts baby um
one last point about that and then i'll
tell you what i suck at um but there
isn't time in the universe to get all of
it um there's a second newsletter there
which is about optimizing learning and
plasticity that touches into some of the
details and some free links and
protocols related to that also at the
newsletter it's the october newsletter
okay so
um what do i suck at oh goodness like
what's your struggles i mean i imagine
now that you're famous your instagram
probably and your twitter are like
blowing up so maybe you're it's hard to
keep track of your email and stay on top
of that
i don't know i'm projecting yeah
so um
three things
um
that have been helpful for uh this but
okay i'm dreadfully poor at communica at
um
follow-up communications i'm really bad
i i really like comments i try and
respond especially on instagram i like
to give people if you ask a professor a
question they're going to give you an
attempt at an answer whether or not it's
accurate or not they're going to try
they're going to try and get it right um
so i have to control my impulse to
respond to everything just for sake of
time so i can do the big important
things um
i'm a terrible cook i'm an absolutely
terrible cook i mean i um i'm fortunate
that i have someone in my life who's an
exceptional cook but i am an absolutely
dreadful cook i mean i can i could
destroy toast i just don't get it right
i don't have the
patience or do you eat really no so my
diet's pretty pretty clean it's
basically um i do low carb i'll eat some
nuts and stuff in the morning if i'm
hungry i don't make a big deal i put
salt in my water which kills your hunger
a lot of the time a lot of people get
shaky they think they need sugar your
your electrolytes are low just put some
sea salt or a little pinch of salt and
water drink it like oh and go another
two hours and your brain functions great
blood volume goes up um so
well you know i think we're gonna i
think 2022 is going gonna be the year
that salt comes back uh science magazine
has done a lot about the hypertension
stuff if you have hypertension check
with your doctor but you know um i eat a
low carb throughout the day
um so meat and salad maybe i might have
a little bit of rice or something if i
train i do exercise i train in the
morning at some point usually i prefer
to do it early but i find some time
where i do one hour of exercise every
it's weight train run like one day
weight training one day run one day
weight train one day run i take one full
day off each week i never train for
longer than an hour after warming up i
hit it as hard as i can because i can't
seem to come off the gas pedal and uh
that's my my thing i've been doing that
for 35 years so i'm 46 now so 32 years
sorry what is um
but i was going to ask you one one
related question which is you talked
about health and kind of like you kind
of mentioned you intermittent fast
basically you don't eat till noon
yeah about that
and you train a certain way and when it
comes to health there's like you know
there's a high carb diet there's a low
carb diet there's there's meat is good
meat is evil there's this is you know uh
weight training is good weight training
is horrible cardio is good cardio is bad
uh so there's sort of this like
bombardment of different side info and i
think you know what you're trying to do
is get to the source of it get to the
truth of things
what is one piece of conventional wisdom
that you disagree with or maybe it's
hipster wisdom something that's a fad or
a trend right now that you you say hey
pump the brakes on that that might be
able to help some people out so what's
something that's you hear a lot but you
don't you don't buy it or you don't
agree with her you think it actually
might be harmful
sure um
i hate to always back pain a little bit
but i have this thing about thoroughness
of answers so forgive me i've got a
little bit of a
ocd on this um uh i i'm terrible at
cooking so i suck at cooking
um and i'm not a good writer i'm not a
bad writer but
verbal in exchange is how i do best so i
i solve this problem i write into i i
dictate into voice uh voice memos and
then i uh put it on what's at rev.com
they have a lot of my personal income
and then i i sculpt from there and um
because i'm not a very good writer so
and i'm a terrible musician i love music
i'm i can't play a chord to save my life
um and i
that's okay i'll live with that so i'm
terrible at a lot of things sam um
and um and if you talk to any of my
ex-girlfriends that they you know
they'll give you their take on what i'm
good at and what i'm not good at you
know um but trust me there are plenty of
things i'm
like world-class failure at and um i
don't try and hide those but i think i'm
glad you asked the question because um
look i don't have it all figured out
um i've been greatly inspired i just
want to give a nod to tim ferriss who
have know only through the podcast
interaction that podcast four hour four
hour work week four hour body
um especially
um
had a tremendous impact in accelerating
my career in science because i was able
to focus on things that really matter
maybe not for just four hours but just
the principles in those books i think we
should all be rereading those books
they're so
damn good
and um
yeah so okay um
the diet thing i do low carb during the
day and then i eat carbohydrates at
night i like starch i like pasta and
salad i try and limit my protein at
night because it makes me so sleepy and
i get into really great sleep uh by
eating my starches later in the day
usually around 8 8 or so i eat dinner
and then i go to sleep around 10 30 or
so i'll have a snack sometimes if i want
one but generally i don't want one um
and that's really really key
because if i've trained early in the day
and i'm running around like crazy i'm
also burning up a lot of glycogen i want
to repack my glycogen so i can train in
the morning so i tend to like to train
uh early in the day okay so what's out
there well first of all the um
the nutrition space is a disaster it's
an absolute disaster
so much so that i'm already preparing
for the attack about what i'm about to
say which is a
well accepted truth in science uh
there's a paper from chris garner um
slab at stanford showing that
as long as people ingest fewer calories
than they burn
you're going to lose weight regardless
of whether or not those calories are in
a low carb regimen or vegan regimen or
pure meat regimen etc
so calories in calories out is a
foundational principle
uh i've been accused of saying different
but the fact of the matter is
it's true now the calories outportion is
going to be regulated by a number of
things basal metabolism how much you
exercise are you hormone augmented are
you well what's what's the controversial
thing that you you've just said though i
don't even know well so so in the
nutrition space there's this other idea
the other idea it's grounded in some
uh rationale which is like for instance
when you eat uh
animal protein like chicken or beef or
fish there's a metabolic cost
there's a there's a calories out
equation
from the digestion and utilization and
protein and use of that yeah but that
seems like a rounding error no
it's not huge but it's very different
than if you were talking about um
equivalent number of calories from from
starch um so it now there but there are
hormonal effects of of biased what i
call bias diet so
i eat a macronutrient complete diet
includes fats and proteins and and
carbohydrates carbohydrates are sort of
on an as-need basis so if i'm training a
little less i might eat a few fewer of
them etc
but
the the nutrition space is a mess
because everyone has to eat
and people have different preferences
and so a lot of the stuff that you see
out there really just geared toward
finding a match with an audience that
prefers plants or prefers meat or
prefers to fast
you know
having explored the fasting science and
literature there's nothing wholly about
fasting that provides autophagy the
cleaning up of dead cells i mean
low-calorie diets will do that also even
if you're not so-called fasting but
there are it appears some benefits to
having periods of each 24-hour cycle
where you're not ingesting calories um
independent of the total number of
calories so the biggest issue i have
that the mess that i see out there that
i hope will get resolved
is that
people are using social media and uh
a certain type of
uh
he said she said they said
we said to amplify controversies that
don't really exist
right i'm willing to bet for instance
i'll just state my stance on this that
eating more plants and less meat forgive
me paul saladino he's a friend of mine
and you know he's the carnivore md he's
got great data to support what he's got
but i like plants i'm gonna eat a salad
am i gonna die
maybe but i'm eating my salad but i'm
also gonna eat a steak and so it's
almost like crazy when we start talking
about this like are we really talking
about this here's what i'd like to see
the carnivore md it's this guy on
instagram so my name do you know who uh
you know the perfect keto guys andrew i
know of them yeah so anthony is lives
across the street from me and then
justin has been on this podcast a bunch
okay um and then there
anthony and this other guy went to
somewhere in africa i forget to see how
this tribe lives eating mostly just meat
and some honey and that other guy his
name is
paul he's got this instagram handle
shown called carnivore md and basically
he pretty much only eats
meat organs and like butter
just animals
yeah he'll do honey and some some
berries and stuff look very smart guy
and um
and
people will come
the battles on the internet like does
dietary cholesterol it impacts serum
cholesterol is syrian cholesterol
um impacting testosterone or not i mean
it's it's so crazy
but the reason it's crazy is not because
it isn't a valid conversation i mean we
all have to eat and people want to live
a long time and feel vital it's crazy
because there's really no field it's not
like vision science or stress science or
sleep science or um
you know cognitive psychology there's no
field it's bringing together people with
very diverse frameworks trying to
resolve the same problem and so it's
sort of like if i were to be in uh
a discussion or agreement with someone
who's a philosopher i don't do
philosophy i don't know the principles
of philosophy so
i think that the issue on the internet
right now is a big one who are the
experts i mean we've seen this with
everything related to kovid right who
are the real experts are they the people
with government jobs are they the people
who
who are
you know mds is it phds i think what i
would like to see more of what i know
i'd like to see more of are more panel
discussions this is one thing that
isn't happening on podcast as much as it
could panel discussions where people can
get to the heart of the matter
by combining physicians scientists and
practitioners i do understand the
frustration and the angst of people
who've devoted a career to being in the
trenches of doing stuff and then someone
who has an md or uh writes a book and
comes along and says hey i've solved
weight loss or i've solved it by way of
eliminating one macronutrient which by
the way is not what paul saladino is
saying i just want to be clear that i um
that's i'm not pointing anything at him
directly when i say that
so i think that um it's a kind of a
free-for-all right now nutrition is the
worst
um but in terms of the battles but there
are some shining uh bright lights in
that space um for instance dr andy
galpin is an exercise physiologist who's
done work with a lot of athletes he's
the professor cal state fullerton in
terms of training regiments he's just
for endurance and for strength for
female athletes and for male athletes
for the everyday person he's got
his content is just so damn solid um and
grounded in mechanism all the way from
muscle sarcomeres to this is how long
you should rest between sets if this is
your goal um and then in the nutrition
space
i've found what works for me which is
this low carb starting around noon and
then gradually transitioning into uh
higher carbohydrates because i eat for
health but i mainly eat for mental and
physical functioning i'm paying
attention to how i feel
and i want to be able to do my work and
so i think that's very important too and
it's a missing piece of the equation
which is it
you know i wouldn't survive a day doing
uh you know six small meals of you know
each macronutrient i'd be
i'd have to cook
uh you know you can break the population
up into kind of these six or ten
you may this might be the ideal diet or
optimal diet for you
or do you think it is hey
the solution you have actually might
work for everybody i like do you think
that i know it's not not to the t of
like you know exactly what you eat but
in terms of
on one side you got completely
plant-based on the other side you got
completely carnivore another side is
just sort of no carb or low carb or slow
carb right there's all these different
varieties do you think the do you think
when it comes to humans knowing what is
the optimal
is it that there are
completely different configurations for
different groups of people or that
actually for humans there actually would
be one sort of optimal diet and then
i have to assume that there's going to
be some genetic bias towards certain
things working so for instance
i lucked out but i also suffer because i
don't like alcohol it just makes me go
to sleep so i don't care if there's
alcohol or not some people really like a
drink um that's probably genetic um it
just doesn't it makes me feel bad it's
not just that it doesn't make me feel
good it makes me feel bad
do you like to get up at all what
do you do you have like drugs do you
like anything
i don't really no i drugs no i i mean
you don't even smoke weed no i i don't
smoke weed i never liked i never liked
marijuana or alcohol very much i'm
my drug is learning and adrenaline i do
i've had to work on the adrenaline part
i've uh there's stories for another time
i've i put myself into some um unhealthy
situations and dangerous situations but
i i come alive with dopamine and
adrenaline in my so you don't know so
you don't do any drugs you don't you
really don't drink i don't drink and do
drugs either but my advice is i'll eat
like a whole box of twinkies when i want
to party that's like i'm like yeah like
i'm playing it like two weeks out i'm
like let's go eat a whole burger party
you know i would say about 85 of the
time i eat clean but um but i'll eat
bread i love bread and i love butter on
it you know basically bread is a vehicle
for butter in my case you know
um and i now watch the plant people are
gonna come out they there's a video they
already came after me like hubert says
butter is
look if you increase your fats your
saturated fats a bit do the blood work
you'll watch your your serum
testosterone go up and we could talk
about testosterone if you want um but
it's not necessarily good for your heart
i didn't say it was good for your heart
i said it's good for your vitality which
is different in the short run than in
the long run but in terms of vices i
like caffeine
i do use certain stimulants
over-the-counter stimulants like i'll
take l-tyrosine these days i take 300
milligrams of alpha gpc if i really want
to laser in i don't do it any more than
two three days a week maximum and that's
also in that second toolkit uh
newsletter um
that and phenylethylamine or
phenylalanine um those two combined and
you're you're in a you're in a focused
tunnel um but i don't touch modafinil i
don't touch stimulants i don't do
recreational drugs
um when i was in college
sure i mean i i partied a bit but also
you know i don't need any
chemical to say exactly what's on my
mind um
or to withhold uh some of the things
that are on my mind so i i'm i just not
been my thing and uh but also i'm
generally training in the morning and i
generally want to get work done
and
you know look i always admired people
that could have a couple beers and relax
because it's such a big part of our
culture
um but that just didn't that's not the
way i went um
you asked about uh in terms of diets and
genetic differences well you know this
is the same thing with sleep and
chronotypes we have people that prefer
to stay up late and wake up late and
people that prefer to wake up early and
then it's a fairly normally distributed
population
uh what should we do about this well for
instance um some people
probably feel better eating more
starches and less protein and maybe more
plants and some people look it looks to
me like joe rogan's doing just fine on
his elk meat and whatever else he's
eating diet i don't know i don't trap he
seems like he's thriving
i will say um in full disclosure that
the people that i know
who are hormone augmented i'm not
talking about big bodybuilders i'm
talking about people that are taking low
dose of of testosterone whether or not
to replace something or not
they tend to crave or at least eat more
proteins um because it increases protein
synthesis and um
you know that's me
yeah yeah so
yeah i'm on it i'm on it now and prior
to being on it i i worked on it for i
did it i tried doing it naturally for
like two years to increase it was like
200 it was so low
and that's slow yeah it was and it
was so low and i was running a company
at the time i was so stressed out so i
like took time off i ate me i squatted
and then i started taking trt and
my life changed oh yeah
it was so crazy that i started eating
more meat and i didn't do it for body
reasons i did it for emotional reasons
but my body changed i feel like a
professional athlete at 32. it's pretty
crazy how much that changed but what you
said on one of your podcasts is it seems
true
is that means i'll likely live
there's a likelihood that i will not
live as long because there was like some
i i don't know if you said someone else
sean they did these studies basically
for some reason there was this group
where they would castrate you in china
um i don't know if it was like done out
of like being like a monk or something
like that yeah yeah and these guys
didn't have dicks anymore and they
castrated them and balls they they
sorry yeah they didn't have balls
anymore yeah and they i mean i didn't do
the experiment nor did i check the data
but i was like they lived longer like
they they consistently lived longer it's
and and like and so like now that i'm on
this i'm like probably maybe i'll i'll
live to be 90 instead of 95 i don't know
who knows what it's going to be
but it's a pretty sick life so that's
kind of the sacrifice that i'm making
yeah well basically the the idea is that
um that your story speaks to is a true
one which is that um vitality and
longevity are on uh they're sort of
orthogonal to one another they're not
counteracting one another but they're
kind of orthogonal to one another and
puberty is the most rapid stage of aging
in our entire life and it's accelerated
aging right i mean puberty is aging it's
just that you're not it's across the you
know you think about it in the context
of a portion of the entire life arc so
introducing
hormones of the sort that were robust
during puberty um will accelerate that
process
you just said that vitality and
longevity are orthogonal basically
meaning
the better and more optimized i want to
feel the less i'm going to live
not necessarily that if they're they're
sort of off-center to one another but
the they're not counteracting one
they're not antagonistic so here let me
explain and um how this would work in
the real world so um
if you will let's use the user's example
you decided to go on testosterone
replacement um your your total
testosterone you said it was in the
somewhere in the 200 nanogram per
deciliter range which is uh below the
normal reference range
so you go on
and
you you're saying uh and quite aptly
that maybe that's going to shorten your
life because of the way that it can
negatively affect lipid profiles and
things the way it affects the liver
there's a lot of biochemistry there we
don't have time to go into but that's
true however
testosterone will also whether or not
it's coming from endogenous sources or
from replacement will also increase your
energy level and your ability to lean
into friction you're going to be running
more you're going to be able to exercise
more so i
have done a number of episodes on
hormones but
one thing that's really important to
understand because i get a lot of
questions about this is that
well the main effect of testosterone is
it makes effort feel good because of the
way that it
you you it makes you there's a readiness
for challenge of all kinds intellectual
challenges
the way that i describe to people is i'm
like i want to fight all the time and
not necessarily fist fight but i just
want to be in a battle whether it's a
battle myself sure yeah yeah i want i
want fight i want to go fight
friction feels good and so um and robert
sapolsky the great robert sapolsky was
on my podcast he said you they've done
these experiments also um with in uh
ultra with altruistic acts of of
friction where people donating money for
instance it's not just beating people up
and this kind of thing so um
but and i'm not suggesting people run
out and get on out onto get on trt i
want to touch on that but basically
so you could say well my blood lipid
profiles are perhaps a bit worse but
with that extra energy you can now start
exercising four times a week plus you
know cardio plus four times a week of
weight training and recover with no
problem provided you're doing the other
things that you need to do whereas if
you weren't you would probably be
depleted there's a depression component
uh and you know your finances would
probably suffer these kinds of things
now some people do not need testosterone
in place i'm gonna just because i think
i'm i'm kind of walking around the
margins and people are probably
wondering all you know is hubermann on
trt um is that what this is about i'm 46
years old i didn't
i didn't touch it until 45
um i went 45 years i've talked about
some of the supplements that can
naturally increase testosterone
you're on trt
oh so from i'm 46 now i started on my uh
at 40 after 45. but let me um so but but
let me explain because i'm actually
coming off so that um that so what i did
is i'm i'm researching a book so i did
45 years of training and sleep and all
the normal things found some supplements
that will increase testosterone
um that's the fedoja and tonga ali you
can see it on that joe rogan episode i
talk a lot about this on the episode
with tim ferriss a number of women are
taking tonga ali as a way to increase
their free testosterone and getting
quite good results
i don't have any relationship whatsoever
to tonga ali or fadoja company i don't
care if you take it definitely check
with your doctor
there are some kind of spooky reports
out there about fadogia and toxicity of
the
cells in the in the testes but those
seem to be limited to rat studies anyway
do your research i'm not telling you
what to do um and you're responsible for
your health not me but those supplements
done properly from the right sources can
increase testosterone by about 200
nanograms per deciliter the most
dramatic i've ever seen is a is a shift
from about 300 to or
high twos to like
you know eights and nines but when i
went but i decided to try trt in this in
a small dose spread throughout the week
um my testosterone at that time was
already sitting in the high eights so i
was doing fine and you i did as an
experiment for part of this book and it
changes your mental frame it makes you
more self-directed more willing to lean
into challenge and
counter to the popular belief it makes
you calmer this is the thing that people
don't realize it gives you more energy
but it makes you calmer
the in primates non-human primates and
in humans
stressed angry
people are the ones that are in the kind
of low-to-mid range of testosterone
typically typically these are averages
from a few studies and i always thought
i always thought well it just makes me
more confident and confident men don't
get upset easily
you know like if someone's like yelling
at me or like there's
like i i'm my masculinity is not being
challenged right now i'm not i'm not
that's why people are like oh so you
want to fight all the time like well
actually no the opposite if someone gets
in my face i'm i'm confident enough that
i could i can
i can walk away you know what i mean
you're in your own you maintain your own
frame you're not gonna get um pulled off
by projection or nowadays the the the
buzzword is gaslighting everyone's
gaslighting everybody without really
under i i'm very interested in
psychoanalysis i've been
fascinated by this for years and this
whole concept of projection is very
interesting how do you actually shift
someone's nervous system this is not a
good thing but how does one shift
their nervous system to change the
mental frame of another nervous system
it's very interesting and kind of spooky
stuff when you start to think about how
your nervous system will frame shift
your frame someone else's frame now this
is vital too when your child or your
partner comes to you and says i really
i'm really stressed about something it
requires a
an adaptive frame shift and you need to
do that people who are autistic who have
asperger's don't frame shift very well
they're very much in their own frame
and they're very good at certain kinds
of things and less good at others
people who are highly empathic are
susceptible empaths will know to getting
yanked down different
frame shift pathways such that they can
oh my god i haven't done anything with
my life because i've been so consumed
with so-and-so's
thinking or feelings around things so
testosterone makes effort feel good i
talk about the effects on the brain
let's leave aside all the effects on the
body and yes it might change blood lipid
profiles but in general
the energy is the component it comprises
a neural energy and an activation stance
where then it's a question of what you
do with that so if you use that as an
excuse to eat a little less well train a
little less then you're no better off
and you might be worse off if you use
that as an opportunity to lean into life
that's wonderful i i work with a number
of professionals and athletes in a kind
of consulting um role to assist with
some of this of course with an
endocrinologist as well new parents for
instance who decide they don't want any
more kids and they're dealing with
lack of sleep and all these things
oftentimes benefit from that and the
relationship can often benefit um for a
number of reasons so this is probably a
whole other discussion i'd be happy to
come on sometime and just talk all about
the hormones because it's all estrogen
is key a lot of people in particular men
are blocking estrogen when they take trt
which is a terrible idea
estrogen promotes brain longevity
estrogen is good for connective tissues
it's good for libido blocking estrogen
is a bad idea in most cases but of
course some people are worried about
water retention or breast development in
males and so they're blocking estrogen
you have to work with an endocrinologist
so it's not testosterone is good
estrogen is bad that is absolutely um
uh that's very sophomore thinking you
know it's it's it's more complex than
that sean did you get your did you get
your
no but i
hit a bunch of people with that uh
that's how i'm going to combat people
you're going to gas light on their
sophomore thinking yeah yeah the gas
lighting thing is funny because you know
gas gaslighting is but basically people
are saying that they're triggering them
right gas lighting is something very
different and uh having um experience
with borderline people that's a very
it's a challenge both for the
borderlines and for the peoples in their
lives that's a real psychiatric
challenge so anytime i see these these
uh valid psychiatric terms being kind of
bastardized on the internet i get i get
a little bit um
uh
well that's one of the challenges right
like pop science pop you know this sort
of like popifying of everything it'll be
more viral right like you know it's easy
to make something viral when you take
away
this causes that
blank statement you know blanket state
to actually get
yeah hearing that um it depends is not
an answer that goes very far but
and here's where i'm hoping there's a
tide change or um which is that if
people can understand mechanism
they can start to understand a little
bit of you know
we have this stress system and we hear
that stress is bad but you know a brief
i just did a podcast episode with duncan
french from the ufc performance
institute duncan's work has shown in
peer-reviewed studies that short-term
stress raises testosterone
stress that lasts more than a day or two
or training sessions that go more than
90 minutes that depletes testosterone so
is stress bad for for reproduction
depends so but if people can understand
mechanism then they can start to
understand hey an ice bath is stress but
it will protect you against illness
because in the short term adrenaline
buffers you against infection because
adrenaline is the signal by which your
immune system says oh my goodness i need
to combat something
so if people can understand mechanism
then it doesn't matter if you're talking
about acupuncture cold bath sauna
lifting weight
sprinting
you know bikram yoga people can i
believe that people are smart and that
if you extend a hand of
that
lend some respect to their intelligence
that they'll come along for the
discussion about mechanism and that even
if i were to get hit by a bus tomorrow
that then they could digest the next
wave of information coming to them in a
much more nuanced way
of course people still need protocol
they need a jumping off point and so
that's why my podcast has been mainly
about that but i think science and
health information on the internet is
changing very quickly um thanks i here
again i just have to say it was seeing
lex friedman's podcast i don't know what
the equivalent is in the
in the finance and entrepreneurial area
maybe it's you guys but in the
kind of general landscape of podcasting
i saw lex's podcast for the first time
and i thought this guy is having really
intense intellectual conversation yeah
he's so good he's so weird in a cool way
he's so interesting he's unique he is
he's kind of punk rock i mean lex is
very punk rock
i mean he's his lifestyle if you think
my lifestyle is unique i mean
lex
well maybe just get him on the podcast
he's a really i'll let him do the
speaking uh for himself but i think that
once someone's out there doing that it's
very hard for people to follow suit with
um the kind of low-level version of that
so what i love and i have listened to
your podcast so i love about your
podcast what i love about ferris and
rogan and lex and rich roll and i'm
missing a few all right i'm going to
regret it later though i'm not
remembering these names but
um because there are others of course is
that
if if sagar and jetty's news channel for
instance remarkable is that if we all
push each other to
constantly try and increase the quality
and the value per unit time of a podcast
even if it's not just protocols but it's
a style of discourse like we've done
today
that to me is going to elevate the
medium
as something that is a serious thing
instead of just the you know chatter do
you uh how big is your audience right
on youtube you've had
10 months so you're that's north of a
million
what about on uh on podcast
uh yeah so well on instagram i think
we're sitting somewhere around like 730
000 followers or something like that um
uh but that's just really i do put out
unique content there that separate from
the podcast from time to time but um
you're gonna laugh but actually and i'm
not cloaking anything i actually don't
tell
know
i don't know i don't know so that's rob
so rob and we have a web a web guy i
mean you gotta if i had a guess like
five to ten million a month that sounds
about right
i think it's on the higher end of that
um i think i know that's right because
if it's about two million per episode in
the first couple weeks is that something
i don't know i'm yeah two million you're
at two million an episode
i i don't know i should ask rob
otherwise
you're killing sorry do you realize
surely tim or whoever has talked to you
and joe has talked to you with two
million downloads an episode dude you
you're rich you're very you could be
very wealthy i'm shocked that you're
still uh
teaching i'm still wearing the same
shirt every day
yeah i looked up before the podcast
average salary before the podcast i was
like this guy could easily be banking a
few million dollars a year and doing the
exact same thing you're doing now it's
not like you'd have to go shift to doing
something else um and i looked at it
i thought what do professors make here's
what i looked up stanford professor this
is what's on the internet no idea if
this is true or not stanford professor
will uh the average professor will make
somewhere between 200 to 225 thousand
dollars uh per year which is obviously a
great living
but i thought that's high for an
academic um
it doesn't for a non-md academic oh the
pay is is it's not just stanford it's
ever it's abysmal um in in the bay area
and i want to be respectful people have
different needs and costs and um but
that's uh in the bay area that that's a
tough tough life for someone with kids
uh you know depends um not tough life
but anyway i'm gonna get some haters for
this but you know what um come hang out
come hang out
you know and have you have you enjoyed
being famous
well okay so a couple of things one
about the the um the views i really do
need to check with rob on the numbers i
don't know i don't track that um i know
we're doing well one thing in the
business side since you have this
audience that um
yeah i only advertise products i
actually use i've been using athletic
greens for over a decade right so i love
that stuff i don't we stay with a
limited number of advertisers insight
trackers
i bought this tracker i use i use my
code huberman huberman yes we work with
thornton thank you uh we work with um
athletic greens is is a re for me was a
really good supplement it's the only one
i set aside money for as a student in
postdoc or as a postdoc and professor
because it covered a lot of things so
expensive though
yeah it i feel better when i take it so
that's why i take it but i get it no
it's it is it's like 150 200 a month i
think
there's a cost there it it
yeah so obviously it has to be within
the scope of someone's decisions of
around finances but the um sleep
cocktail so we work with thorn um
because the great thing about thorn is
the quality of their supplements is so
good that you can actually take less of
thorn supplements in my experience and
get away with it but there are other
great supplement companies out there i'm
not here to plug the our sponsors but i
do um obviously that's the way podcasts
make money and i pay my staff um which
is rob and mike and ian and we have a
few others as well i should mention one
thing about the the medium
and as a business model so
i've never
talked about this but the hubermann lab
podcast is but one of several podcasts
um under a company that i founded um
with rob
so david sinclair from harvard genetics
um
yeah professor jones at harvard lifespan
right
lifespan so he's launching the lifespan
podcast with davidson
and you're owning this
yeah i own that brilliant
podcast network
yeah so um
and so we're working on the front end
and back end materials of that me and
mike blayback are the creatives on that
with that
aesthetic and the and it'll be very
different than mine right because david
um i mean he's you know i wouldn't we're
different david
you're beating
you're building this media business all
sitting around longevity and healthy
longevity mental and and physical health
i don't know we'll call it mental
fitness that's a word that we've used
mental fitness
you're going to crush this this is going
to be here thanks well the goal is
really that um for instance many
professors have excellent information
they can share on gut microbiome on
addiction on adhd that goes well beyond
the depth that i can provide in one of
my episodes
and so they need to do six or seven
episodes but they probably don't need to
do an a podcast in perpetuity and so the
idea is to have a set of podcasts that
you can come to
mine if you like david's if you like
maybe you god forbid you have a
relative dealing with parkinson's and
hear from somebody what you can really
do about that or alzheimer's or you have
a kid and you want to know what are the
science-based practices
for getting a kid to sleep and for
neuroplasticity in a child well let's
talk to a world expert in that um and
and so the the the idea is to have an
umbrella for multiple podcasts the
huberman lab podcast is but one of those
that i plan to continue david's is going
to be the second and we've got a third
and a fourth that are revving up now and
who knows maybe we should do one on um i
don't know some something related to
crypto or something i don't i only know
what i know and i know academics i know
science and i know medicine and so
that's what i'm going to bring to the
table this is awesome this is awesome i
had this
thank you while back which was i
remember thinking about my favorite
science
uh he was great but he would and i just
thought about like his kind of like
sphere of impact like he could you know
each class had about 20 kids he would
teach five classes a day so we teach
about 100 kids a day
and so you know his reach as like
my best teacher growing up was a hundred
students a day a hundred students a year
essentially
and then with the internet i just
thought wow this is going to change the
best teachers in the world are going to
have millions of students and they're
going to make millions of dollars as
they should um for being amazing
teachers and i've always been looking
out for and i've been investing and
every platform i can get my hands on
anywhere i can see that teachers are
able to do that where they're able to
scale and have millions of students and
have because you know if i'm going to
learn math or i'm going to learn about
nutrition i can either learn locally
like that's the way the world always
worked i just learned from my best local
teacher that was available to me or now
i can learn globally so i can find
actually who is the best at not only
being an expert but packaging it and
conveying it in a way that's
entertaining that's relatable that's
that fits me right and so you know
that's what you're doing you're the
perfect example of something i've been
thinking
why isn't the world moving this way and
actually it is it's just it wasn't
through online school it was through
things like podcasting
and and it's more popular in other
countries you know china and does a
really good job of this they've got a
we've done some
chinese teachers who've who make tens of
millions of dollars a year superstar
they're like musicians and athletes
yeah same with india you know sean we
have that you sent that you shared with
me that really cool photo of a guy in
india teaching math and it looked like
he was a comedian because there was like
uh andre
this guy his name is biju no he's a guy
in india i'll have to check it out
teacher he would teach in like local
villages and people love learning math
from them so he would go to other cities
and they would come find him because it
had spread through word of mouth
eventually he was filling up stadiums
free free you know free to attend he was
just teaching math on a projector in a
20 000 person stadium and now he created
he created an app it's like a 10 billion
dollar education app in india but you
know like that was his origin story and
i thought that was
i love it you know and and i love the
model around podcasting because yes you
have to tolerate some ads but
advertisers are happy consumers are
happy
and it's zero cost to consumer that to
me is like if ever there was order in in
a universe not the universe but in a
universe that's that's it yes but it it
it sucks so
do you know what do you know my company
at all or did you know my company
i'm afraid i don't know it's all good so
it's all good so we owned this and then
we owned this thing called i started
this company called the hustle which was
a daily email that reached about 2
million people a day for business news
we just sold it to hubspot for many tens
of millions of dollars and um we are
making you know 20 million dollars on
ads
so we made a lot of money and the
problem with ads is it's cool when
you're doing it now because you can pick
and choose thorn athletic greens you can
pick and choose cool and that's
exactly how we started but then you get
staff and you're like all right we're
gonna try and triple every year and so
in order to triple every year like
there's not that many thorns and
athletic greens then you gotta go look
at like some other and you're
like well
we gotta hit these growth numbers and so
it's so it kind of you
i don't think he worships at the altar
of your over your
well maybe you know no but you always
think about it for example what if i
talked about athletic greens and
let's say they did something kind of
wrong and you you you don't happen well
that's my point that's exactly my point
you will say well i don't know you know
i mean wait it's even the most honest
people and good people you are everyone
we're all incentivized something and so
maybe like he would be willing to defend
them a little bit more because they're
giving them money which is a natural
thing you know what i mean yeah yeah so
that is an issue i mean i think that um
and we do care about growth um but and
the reason we built out a philanthropic
arm of this company is because i really
i empathize with the struggle that
academic scientists live in day to day
which is that
they don't have time to do their own
research let alone
work for the world which is what they're
really hired to do their grants come
mainly from public sources so we're
trying to think about ways that we can
start to pump some money back into
science through the podcast so money
coming into the podcast actually
represents some of it money going back
into the scientific community to do
better work we're starting to explore
nfts and some of how that might be
incorporated um twitter's a great place
to learn about that i just want to say
that the nft landscape and crypto
landscape people are so kind it's like
they're trying to come one it's kind of
all in it kind of reminds me of the
early punk rock movement it's like you
they know
i'm paying attention to their energy i
don't understand a darn thing about it
is punk rock it is very punk rock
everybody would love to sell you their
token and their currency and why it's
yeah just wait everybody says let me
tell you about it because they are we're
all you know selling our own holdings
basically interesting wait until you say
something bad about them though
okay well i i tend yeah i i hope not to
do that at least not by accident but i i
just noticed that um there's a there's i
love the diy spirit look i'm a patriot
too i'm sure you have an international
audience but look
my dad's a first generation immigrant
this this country is amazing
from argentina so he's not you know he
wasn't from some place where he was
stricken but he came here on a navy
scholarship he's a physicist um
you know this is a country where
you can make lateral moves it's hard to
ascend all right and we we should
acknowledge that not everyone starts in
the same place and and the the slope is
different for different people no
question but you can make lateral moves
here and the you know think about this
the nobel prize is given each year for
instance
um the world is big the world of science
is big
most nobel prizes include or are given
to people in the u.s and we have one of
the most difficult funding schemes for
getting money to do research in this
country now compared to third world
countries we're very wealthy in the
research realm but compared to other
countries where they basically stock the
laboratories with money
it's it's incredible here we have these
individual labs like doing little like
startup style workshop stuff it's that
grind it's that leaning into friction
that
i really believe is is the
hallmark of
future development and so science
doesn't have that we didn't have a
podcast platform or information platform
and i'm hoping that
my podcast and the others like david's
and the other ones that come out through
our company will will soon populate i'd
love to see more of this done out there
there's you know there's some smart
guy or gal that is out there thinking
like hmm like i'm gonna i'm gonna do the
podcast on amphibians because i love
frogs and i'm gonna like tell people
which terrarium to get and like it's
gonna be the terrarium the podcast and
you never know what's gonna what's gonna
work but i love that spirit the
entrepreneurial spirit so it's what
we're trying to bring well dude thanks
for coming on this is badass we um we
haven't done a podcast this long in a
long time by the way we had i'll tell
you really quick we had rob dierdick on
recently oh yeah and uh he is uh i
forget what we were talking about
skateboarding and like wealth or
something but he's like the wealthiest
yeah rob wouldn't know me but he's tight
with mike blayback because rob and big
big unfortunately passed away um and
mike did all the photos for that um
and uh yeah look skateboarders if you
want to know what's really cool and how
to do the real diy spirit you just
skateboarders they just i'm gonna go i'm
gonna brat i'm gonna brag after this i'm
gonna send you a video of my latest
three
oh and yeah i can't i ca i've got no tre
flip but the um i rat a pool but i'm i'm
not i'm not that good dude you're you're
a badass man i'm i'm so excited to talk
to you i feel inspired after having a
conversation with you you're very you're
you're very interested
much bigger
deal oh well we got to speak
oh well i want to say genuine thanks for
having me on i felt immediate resonance
i'm very much like a can sense that so i
i think it'd be great to get together in
person sometimes do people still do that
i don't know
are you in california you're in northern
california
i split my time now between the bay area
and southern california so where are you
guys
yeah we both we both lived there i lived
in san francisco for eight or nine years
i just bought a house in texas and so
i'm in austin as of now but i'm a little
bit nomadic so i'm
but well i'm gonna be in austin a bunch
because i hang out with lex there he's
going to take me to jiu jitsu again last
time
he lives in austin
i've never done it before he's a black
belt so i don't know he lives
but dude i have a i have a gym here at
my house like a really nice gym and i
have people come over and we can lift
heavy i lift heavy and also uh we could
box i beat people up all the time so if
you want to fight right do that
we could we could probably
i just
this is not this is not a uh we probably
shouldn't box i i boxed i had my boxing
card and boxed pretty consistently uh
various times i'm not very good you
don't get a nose like this do a yoga um
so
let's not box come on man i got a rower
we can do anything you want i'm fit this
this is the this is the trt speaking
folks
um it would be great fun i'll pass you
guys my number by email just let's text
we're in the room and uh we'll take it
into the real world thank you man great
to have you thanks
travel never looking back
you